hello everyone and welcome to this
interactive full course session by
simply learn on cryptography and network
security
in this course we will look into various
aspects of cryptography its varying
attributes and important points related
to network security that protects our
sensitive information over the internet
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update from
us
let's begin with taking a look at the
agenda for today's session
we will start session by learning about
the need for cryptography and its role
in online matters
moving on we will look into some basic
terms related to cryptography and its
application and historical significance
next we will learn multiple ways to
apply cryptography which are symmetric
cryptography
asymmetric encrypted cryptography
and hashing
with the understanding of basic
cryptography terms we will now move on
to more complex topics related to
cryptography algorithms which are data
encryption standards des algorithm
advanced encryption standard aes
algorithm
digital signature algorithm
revisit shameer adelman
encryption
message digest 5 md5 algorithm
with the completion of path related to
cryptography algorithms we will move on
to applications of cryptography
which are
secure hash algorithm sha
secure socket layer ssl handshake
diffie helm and key exchange
and to finish off the session on
cryptography we will look into some
popular and important interview
questions on the topic
now let's take a look at the agenda for
network security
to begin with we will look into what is
network security
working steps involved in the network
security
different types of network security
following with some details regarding
the transport and application layer
security
and moving on with introduction to some
key points
related to key tools of network security
along with the benefits of network
security
and a live session demo on
live and map working
let's begin
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography
meet ann
ann wanted to look for a decent discount
on the latest iphone she started
searching on the internet and found a
rather shady website that offered a 50
discount on the first purchase
once and submitted her payment details a
huge chunk of money was withdrawn from a
bank account just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was a
http web page instead of an https one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers had she used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iphone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident
this is why it's never recommended to
visit unknown websites or share any
personal information on them
now that we understand why cryptography
is so important let's now understand
what cryptography is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the secure storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is the primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply learn is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text
the only ones who can are the people who
know how to decrypt the coded word
thereby reversing the process of
encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers they are a set of
detailed steps to be carried out one
after the other to make sure the data
becomes as unreadable as possible until
it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data
this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on whatsapp every day
all of which are secured thanks to
end-to-end encryption
there is a huge market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
julius caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table
a spy can't decipher the original
message at first glance for example if
he wanted to pass confidential
information to his armies and decides to
use the substitution shift of plus 2 a
becomes c b becomes d and so on the word
attack when passed through a
substitution shift of plus 3 becomes dw
defn
this cipher has been appropriately named
the caesar cipher which is one of the
most widely used algorithms
the enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the nazi german armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political
military and administrative information
and it consisted of three or more rotors
that scrambled the original message
depending on the machine state at that
time the decryption is similar but it
needs both machines to stay in the same
state before passing the cipher text so
that we received the same plain text
message
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography
both of these categories have their pros
and cons and differ only by the
implementation today we are going to
focus exclusively on symmetric key
cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted
with so many aspects of banking moving
on to the internet having a reliable
safety net is crucial
symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud and boosts the
security index of these payment gateways
in general
[Music]
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit and rests on
servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
assurance of minor to no delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure http website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first before moving
on to the specific algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into cipher text and vice
versa
as you can see in the image the key used
for encryption is the same key needed
for decrypting the message at the other
end the secret key shouldn't be sent
along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the diffie-hellman
key exchange protocol for example
for example if paul wants to send a
simple message to jane they need to have
a single encryption key that both of
them must give secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message i am ready is
converted into ciphertext using a
specific substitution cipher by paul in
that case jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decrypt the
ciphertext once it reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid-transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to snoop in
the symmetric key algorithms like the
data encryption standard have been in
use since the 1970s while the popular
ones like the ees have become the
industry standard today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of paramount importance to keep
it secret on all occasions
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption is it
becomes a single point of failure anyone
who gets their hand on it can read all
the encrypted messages and do so mainly
without the knowledge of the sender and
the receiver
so it is the priority to keep the
encryption and encryption key private at
all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message
upon receiving the message and
decrypting it with the key it is
impossible to guess its origin
if the sender somehow transmits the
secret key along with the cipher text
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public
provided we managed to keep the key
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information in symmetric key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a look
stream ciphers are the algorithms that
encrypt basic information one bit at a
time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it relies on a
single bit or byte to do the encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format
in stream ciphers each binary digit is
encrypted one after the other
the most popular ones are the rc4 salsa
and panama
the binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bit stream
upon passing it through we receive the
ciphertext that can be transferred to
the receiver without fear of
man-in-the-middle attacks
the binary data can be passed through an
algorithmic function
it can have either x or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or hexadecimal format to give our final
ciphertext
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size the size of these blocks
depend on the exact cipher being used a
128-bit block cipher will break the
plain text into blocks of 128 bit each
and encrypt those blocks instead of a
single digit
once these blocks are encrypted
individually they are chained together
to form a final cipher text
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process
once the conversion is complete the
blocks are passed through the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get our ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like aes des and 3des are all
block cipher methodology subsets
with so many factors coming into play
there are quite a few things symmetrical
cryptography excels at while falling
short in some other
symmetric key cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography there is
only one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption
similarly the performance of symmetric
encryption is much more efficient under
similar computational limitations fewer
calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets
thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetric key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt vast amounts of data with very
less overhead we took a look at
symmetric key cryptography
we used a single private key for both
the encryption and decryption of data
and it works very well in theory let's
take a look at a more realistic scenario
now
let's meet joe
joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with ryan via long distance
messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now joe can easily use symmetric key
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says but here's the tricky part
how will joe send the required
decryption key to ryan
the sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text
if someone intercepts the key while
transmitting it there is no use in
employing cryptography since a third
party can now decode all the information
easily
key sharing is a risk that will always
exist when symmetric key cryptography is
being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem
let's understand what asymmetric key
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key a
public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the data post
transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can be shared via
messaging blog posts or key servers and
there are no restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the ciphertext the ciphertext is
then transmitted to the receiver without
any other key on getting the ciphertext
the receiver uses his private key to
decrypt it and get the plain text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetry key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message and the
private key which can decrypt the
message need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible
to understand this better take the
analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you
in a way you can say the mailbox is
publicly available to all but only you
have access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play
no one can intercept the message and
read its contents since it's encrypted
once the receiver gets its contents he
can use his private key to decrypt the
information
both the public key and private key are
generated so they are interlinked and
you cannot substitute other private keys
to decrypt the data
in another example if alice wants to
send a message to bob
let's say it reads call me today she
must use bob's public key while
encrypting the message
upon receiving the cipher message bob
can proceed to use his private key in
order to decrypt the message and hence
complete securities attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many uses in areas that
require high confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signature
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography senders can now sign
documents with their private keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sender's
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification width with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows a
similar approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetry key
cryptography is used to authorize
transactions and maintain the system
thanks to its two key structures changes
are reflected across the blockchain's
peer-to-peer network only if it is
approved from both ends
along with asymmetric key cryptography's
tamper-proof architecture its
non-repudiation characteristic also
helps in keeping the network stable
we can also use asymmetric key
cryptography combined with symmetric
cryptography to monitor ssl or tls
encrypted browsing sessions to make sure
nobody can steal our personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general
it plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure http website
format security parameters differ on a
session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to modern data
security
another great use of the asymmetric key
cryptography structure is transmitting
keys for symmetric key cryptography with
the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming the original message is
first encrypted using a symmetric key
the key used for encrypting the data is
then converted into the cipher text
using the receiver's public key now we
have two cipher text to transmit to the
receiver on receiving both of them the
receiver uses his private key to decrypt
the symmetry key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetric cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions encrypting the key
using asymmetric algorithms will
definitely be more memory efficient and
secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography
let us understand why asymmetric falls
under the public key cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal
the encryption key is available to
everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system to
put that into perspective we share an
email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling since
there is nothing hidden from the world
if they want to send us any encrypted
information this category is called the
public key cryptography with so many
variables in play there must be some
advantages that give asymmetrically
cryptography an edge over the
traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies
let's go through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recrypt any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance
we have much more extensive key lengths
in rsa encryption and other asymmetric
algorithms like 2048 bits key and 4096
bit keys
larger keys are much harder to break
into via brute force and are much more
secure
asymmetric key cryptography can use as a
proof of authenticity since only the
rightful owner of the keys can generate
the messages to be decrypted by the
private key the situation can also be
reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot be intercepted
and changed without invalidating the
private key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate when and where the case
requires
before getting too deep into the topic
let's get a brief overview of how
hashing works
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of information or data beyond
recognition
we can achieve this by using hash
functions which are essentially
algorithms that perform mathematical
operations on the main plain text
the value generated after passing the
plaintext information through the hash
function is called the hash value digest
or in general just the hash of the
original data
while this may sound similar to
encryption the major difference is
hashes are meant to be irreversible no
decryption key can convert a digest back
to its original value
however a few hashing algorithms have
been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in news among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification etc
like we discussed earlier websites use
hashing to store the user's passwords so
how do they make use of these hash
passwords
when a user signs up to create a new
account the password is then run through
the hash function and the resulting hash
value is stored on the servers
so the next time a user comes to login
to the account the password he enters is
passed through the same hash function
and compared to the hash stored on the
main server
if the newly calculated hash is the same
as the one stored on the website server
the password must have been correct
because according to hash functions
terminology same inputs will always
provide the same outputs
if the hashes do not match then the
password entered during login is not the
same as the password entered during the
sign up hence the login will be denied
this way no plain text passwords get
stored preventing both the owner from
snooping on user data and protecting
users privacy in the unfortunate event
of a data breach or a hack
apart from password storage hashing can
also be used to perform integrity checks
when a file is uploaded on the internet
the files hash value is generated and it
is uploaded along with the original
information
when a new user downloads the file he
can calculate the digest of the
downloaded file using the same hash
function
when the hash values are compared if
they match then file integrity has been
maintained and there has been no data
corruption
since so much important information is
being passed on to the hash function we
need to understand how they work
a hash function is a set of mathematical
calculations operated on two blocks of
data
the main input is broken down into two
blocks of similar size
the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being used
hash functions are designed to be one
way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by design
some algorithms like the previously
mentioned md5 have been compromised but
most secure algorithms are being used
today like the sha family of algorithms
the digest size is also dependent on the
respective algorithm being used md5 has
a digest of 128 bits while she 256 has a
digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not reversible
there are certain requirements of a hash
function that need to be met before they
are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively fast pace
but it also shouldn't be very fast
running the algorithm on all cylinders
makes the functions easy to boot force
and a security liability
there must be a balance to allow the
hash function to handle large amounts of
data and not make it ridiculously easy
to brute force by running through all
the possible combinations
the hash function must be dependent on
each bit of the input
the input can be text audio video or any
other file extension
if a single character is being changed
it doesn't matter how small that
character may be the entire digest must
have a distinctly different hash value
this is essential to create unique
digests for every password that is being
stored
but what if two different users are
using the same password
since the hash function is the same for
all users both the digest will be the
same
this is called a hash collision
you may think this must be a rare
occasion where two users have exactly
the same password but that is not the
case
we have techniques like salting that can
be used to reduce these hash collisions
as we will discuss later in this video
you would be shocked to see the most
used passwords of 2020.
all of these passwords are laughably
insecure and since many people use the
same passwords repeatedly on different
websites cash collisions risks are more
common than one would expect
let's say the hash functions find two
users having the same password
how can they store both the hashes
without messing up the original data
this is where salting and peppering come
to play
salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function
this random keyword is unique for each
user on the system and it is called the
salt value or just the sort
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the solved value will differ and so
will they digest
there is a small problem in this process
though
since the salt is unique for each user
they need to be stored in the database
along with the passwords and sometimes
even in plain text to speed up the
process of continuous verification
if the server is hacked then the hashes
will need to be brute forced which takes
a lot of time but if they receive the
salts as well the entire process becomes
very fast
this is something that peppery aims to
solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case
the paper isn't stored on the servers it
is mostly hard coded onto the website
source code since it's going to be the
same for all credentials
this way even if the servers get hacked
they will not have the right pepper
needed to crack into all the passwords
many websites use a combination of
salting and preparing to solve the
problem of hash collision and bolster
security
since brute force takes such a long time
many hackers avoid taking the effort the
returns are mostly not worth it and the
possible combinations of using both
salting and peppery is humongous in
today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is aes
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available
other primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the des the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of aes
des algorithm stands for data encryption
standard
it is a symmetric key cipher that is
used to encrypt and recrypt information
in a block by block manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they are later chained together to form
our final cipher text which is then sent
to a receiver
des takes the original unaltered piece
of data called the plain text in a
64-bit block and it is converted into an
encrypted text that is called the
ciphertext
it uses 48-bit keys during the
encryption process and follows a
specific structure called the fiscal
cipher structure during the entire
process
it is a symmetric key algorithm which
means des can reuse the keys used in the
encryption format to decrypt the
ciphertext back to the original plain
text
once the 64-bit blocks are encrypted
they can be combined together before
being transmitted
let's take a look at the origin and the
reason the es was founded
des is based on a fiscal block cipher
called lucifer developed in 1971 by ibm
cryptography researcher host fistel
the es uses 16 rounds of the swisstal
structure using a different key for each
round
it also utilizes a random function with
two inputs and provides a single output
variable
the es became the organization's
approved encryption standard in november
1976 and was later reaffirmed as a
standard in 1983 1988 and finally in
1999
but eventually the es was cracked and it
was no longer considered a secure
solution for all official rules of
communication
consequently triple ds was developed
triple gs is a symmetric key block
cipher that uses a double ds cipher
encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using ds for encrypting messages
in order to search for a better
alternative a public-wide competition
was organized and helped cryptographers
develop their own algorithm as a
proposal for the next global standard
this is where the rndial algorithm came
into play and was later credited to be
the next advanced encryption standard
for a long time des was the standard for
data encryption for data security
its rule ended in 2002 when finally the
advanced encryption standard replaced
des as an acceptable standard following
a public competition for a place
to understand the structure of a fistal
cipher we can use the following image as
a reference
the block being encrypted is divided
into two parts one of which is being
passed on to the function while the
other part is xor with the function's
output
the function also uses the encryption
key that differs for each individual
round
this keeps going on until the last step
until where the right hand side and the
left hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final ciphertext
for the decryption process the entire
procedure is reversed starting from the
order of the keys to the block sorting
if the entire process is repeated in a
reverse order we will eventually get
back our plane text and this simplicity
helps the speed
overall this was later detrimental to
the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was compromised
a fiscal block cipher is a structure
used to derive many symmetric block
ciphers such as des which as we have
discussed in our previous comment
crystal cipher proposed a structure that
implements substitution and permutation
alternately so that we can obtain
ciphertext from the plain text and vice
versa this helps in reducing the
redundancy of the program and increases
the complexity to combat brute force
attacks
the pistol cipher is actually based on
the shannon structure that was proposed
in 1945.
the fistel cipher is the structure
suggested by horst feistel which was
considered to be a backbone while
developing many symmetric block ciphers
the shannon structure highlights the
implementation of alternate confusion
and diffusion
and like we already discussed the fiscal
cipher structure can be completely
reversed depending on the data
however we must consider the fact that
to decrypt the information by reversing
the physical structure we will need the
exact polynomial functions and the key
orders
to understand how the blocks are being
calculated we take a plane test which is
of 64-bit and when it is later divided
into two equal halves of 32 bit each
in this the right half is immediately
transferred to the next round to become
the new left half of the second row
the right hand is again passed off to a
function which uses an encryption key
that is unique to each round in the
pistol cipher
whatever the function gives off as an
output it is passed on as an xor input
with the left half of the initial plain
text
the next output will become the right
half of the second round for the plain
text
this entire process constitutes of a
single round in the fisted cipher
taking into account what happens in a
polynomial function
we take one half of the block and pass
it through an expansion box the work of
the expansion box is to increase the
size of the half from 32-bit to 48-bit
text
this is done to make the text compatible
to a 48-bit keys we have generated
beforehand
once we pass it through the xor function
we get a 48-bit text as an output
now remember a half should be of 32-bit
so this 48-bit output is then later
passed on to a substitution box this
substitution box reduces its size from
48 bit to 32 bit output which is then
later xored with the first half of the
plain text
a block cipher is considered the safest
if the size of the block is large but
large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption
screen
generally the size is 64 bit
sometimes modern block ciphers like aes
have a 128 bit block size as well
the security of the block server
increases with increasing key size
but larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process
earlier 64-bit keys were considered
sufficient modern ciphers need to use
128-bit keys due to the increasing
complexity of today's computational
standards
the increasing number of rounds also
increased the security of the block
cipher
similarly they are inversely
proportional to the speed of encryption
a highly complex round function enhances
the security of the block cipher always
we must maintain a balance between the
speed and security
the symmetric block cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed
there is no use of an algorithm it
cannot be implemented in a real life
framework that can help organizations to
encrypt or decrypt the data in a timely
manner
now that we understand the basics of
pistol ciphers we can take a look at how
des manages to run through 16 rounds of
the structure and provide the cipher
text at the end
now that we understand the basics of
crystal cybers we can take a look at how
des manages to run through 16 rounds of
this structure and provide a cipher text
in simple terms ds takes the 64-bit
plaintext and converts it into a 64-bit
cipher text and since we are talking
about these symmetric algorithms the
same key is being used when it is
decrypting the data as well
we first take a 64-bit clip plain text
and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the initial
permission function has the job of
dividing the block into two different
parts so that we can perform fiscal
cipher structures on it
there are multiple rounds being procured
in the ds algorithm namely 16 rounds of
pistol cipher structure
each of these rounds will need keys
initially we take a 56 bit cipher key
but it is a single key
we pass it on to a round key generators
which generate 16 different keys for
each single round that the pistol cipher
is being run
these keys are passed on to the rounds
as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bits keys is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation bonds in the polynomial
functions of the special ciphers
when passing through all these rounds we
reach round 16 but the final key is
passed on from the round key generator
and we get a final permutation in the
final permutation the rhymes are swapped
and we get our final ciphertext
this is the entire process of des with
16 rounds of pistol servers encompassed
in it to decrypt our ciphertext back to
the plain text we just have to reverse
the process we did in the des algorithm
and reverse the key order along with the
functions
this kind of simplicity is what gave des
the bonus when it comes to speed but
eventually it was detrimental to the
overall efficiency of the program when
it comes to security factors
bes have five different modes of
operation to choose from
this one of those is electronic code
book
each 64-bit block is encrypted and
decrypted independently in the
electronic code book format we also have
cipher block chaining or the cbc method
here each 64-bit block depends on the
previous one and all of them use an
initialization vector
we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding ciphertext
becomes the input for the encryption
algorithm
it produces a pseudo random output which
in turn is xored with the plain text
there is an output feedback method as
well which is the same as cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the
output from the preceding des
a counter method has a different way of
approach where each plaintext block is
xored with an encrypted counter the
counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block
there are a few other alternatives to
these modes of operation but the five
mentioned above are the most widely used
in the industry and recommended by
cryptographers worldwide
let's take a look at the future of tes
the dominance of des ended in 2002 when
the advanced encryption standard
replaced the ds encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done by
following a public competition to find a
replacement
nist officially withdrew the global
acceptance standard in may 2005 although
triple des has approved for some
sensitive government information through
2030.
nist also had to change the ds algorithm
because its key length was too short
given the increased processing power of
the new computers
encryption power is related to the size
of the queue and des found itself a
victim of ongoing technological advances
in computing we have received a point
where 56 bit was no longer a challenge
to the computers of tracking
note that because ds is no longer the
nist federal standard does not mean that
it is no longer in use triple ds is
still used today and is still considered
a legacy encryption algorithm
in our last video we saw how the data
encryption standard also known as des
became the global standard for
encryption and data security
eventually with so much computing power
growth the need for a stronger algorithm
was necessary to safeguard our personal
data
as solid as des was the computers of
today could easily break the encryption
with repeated attempts thereby rendering
the data security helpless
to counter this dilemma a new standard
was introduced which was termed as the
advanced encryption standard or the aes
algorithm
let's learn what is advanced encryption
standard
the aes algorithm also known as the
rindyle algorithm is a symmetric block
cipher with a block size of 128 bits
it is converted into cipher text using
keys of 128 192 or 256 bits it is
implemented in software and hardware
throughout the world to encrypt
sensitive data
the national institute of standards and
technology also known as nist started
development on aes in 1997 when it was
announced the need for an alternative to
the data encryption standard
the new internet needed a replacement
for des because of its small key size
with increasing computing power it was
considered unsafe against entire key
search attacks
the triple ds was designed to overcome
this problem however it was deemed to be
too slow to be deployed in machines
worldwide
strong cases were present by the mars
rc-6 serpent and the two fish algorithms
but it was the rindal encryption
algorithm also known as aes which was
eventually chosen as the standard
symmetric key encryption algorithm to be
used
its selection was formalized with the
release of federal information
processing standards publication 197 in
the november of 2001. it was approved by
the u.s secretary of commerce
now that we understand the origin of aes
let us have a look at the features that
make aes encryption algorithm unique
the aes algorithm uses a substitution
permutation or sp network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a cipher text
it has a series of linked operations
including replacing inputs with specific
outputs that is substitutions and others
that involve bit shuffling which is
permutations
at the beginning of the encryption
process we only start out with a single
key which can be either a 128-bit key a
192-bit key or a 256-bit key eventually
this one key is expanded to be used in
multiple rounds throughout the
encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly aes performs all its
calculations on byte data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the ds
algorithm
therefore aes treats 128 bits of a clear
text block as 16 bytes
the number of rounds during the
encryption process depends on the key
size that is being used
the 128 bit key size fixes 10 rounds the
192 bit key size fixes 12 rounds and the
256 bit key holds 14 rounds
a round key is required for each of
these rounds but since only one key is
input into the algorithm the single key
needs to be expanded to get the key for
each round including the round zero
with so many mathematical calculations
going on in the background there are
bound to be a lot of steps throughout
the procedure
let's have a look at the steps followed
in aes
before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of aes encryption
everything in the process is stored in a
four into four matrix format
this matrix is also known as a state
array and we'll be using these state
arrays to transmit data from one step to
another and from one round to the next
round
each round takes straight arrow as input
and gives a straight array as output to
be transferred into the next round
it is a 16 byte matrix with each cell
representing one byte
with each four bytes representing a word
so every state array will have a total
of four words representing it
as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in
let's say the number of rounds are n
then the key has to be expanded to be
used with n plus 1 rounds because the
first round is the key 0 round
let's say n is the number of rounds the
key is expanded to n plus 1 rounds it is
also a state array having 4 words in its
vicinity
every key is used for a single round and
the first key is used as a round key
before any round begins
in the very beginning the plain text is
captured and passed through an xor
function with the round key as a
supplement
this key can be considered the first key
from the n plus 1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a byte
substitution process
beyond that there is a provision to
shift rows in the state arrays
later on the state array is mixed with a
constant matrix to shuffle its column in
the mix column segment
after which we add the round key for
that particular round
the last four steps mentioned are part
of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through
the state arrays are then passed from
one round to the next as an input
in the last round however we skip the
mix columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining unchanged
but what are these byte substitution and
row shifting processes let's find out
regarding each step in more detail
in the first step the plain text is
stored in a state array and it is
exhausted with the k0 which is the first
key in the expanded key set
this step is performed only once on a
block while being repeated at the end of
each round as per iteration demands
the state array is xored with the key to
get a new state array which is then
passed off as input to the sub bytes
process
in the second stage we have byte
substitution
we leverage an xbox called as a
substitution box to randomly switch data
among each element
every single byte is converted into a
hexadecimal value having two parts the
first part denotes the row value and the
second part denotes the column value
the entire state array is passed through
the s box to create a brand new state
array which is then passed off as an
input to the row shifting process
the 16 input bytes are replaced by
looking at a fixed table given in the
design we finally get a matrix with four
rows and four columns
when it comes to row shifting each bit
in the four rows of the matrix is
shifted to the left
an entry that is a fall off is
reinserted to the right of the line the
change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left
the third line is shifted two positions
to the left and the fourth line is
shifted three positions to the left
the result is a new matrix that contains
the same 16 bytes but has been moved in
relation to each other to boost the
complexity of the program
in mixed columns each column of 4 bytes
is now replaced using a special
mathematical function
the function takes 4 bytes of a column
as input and outputs 4 completely new
bytes
we will get a new matrix with the same
size of 16 bytes and it should be noted
that this phase has not been done in the
last round of the iteration
when it comes to adding a round key the
16 bytes of the matrix are treated as
128 bits and the 128 bits of the round
key are xor
if it is the last round the output is
the cipher text
if you still have a few rounds remaining
the resulting 128 bits are interpreted
as 16 bytes and we start another similar
round
let's take an example to understand how
all these processes work
if our plain text is the
string 2 1 9 2 we first convert it into
a hexadecimal format as follows
we use an encryption key which is that's
my kungfu and it is converted into a
hexadecimal format as well
as per the guidelines we use a single
key which is then later expanded into n
plus 1 number of keys in which case is
supposed to be 11 keys for 10 different
rounds
in round 0 we add the round key the test
is xored with the k0 and we get a state
array that is passed off as an input to
the substitution by its process
when it comes to the substitution bytes
process we leverage an s box to
substitute the elements of each byte
with a completely new byte
this way the state array that we receive
is passed off as an input to the row
shifting process of the next step
it comes to row shifting each element is
shifted a few places to the left with
the first row being shifted by zero
places second row by one place third row
by two places and the last by three
the state array that we received from
the row shifting is passed off as an
input to mix columns
in mixed columns we multiply the
straight array with a constant matrix
after which i receive a new state error
to be passed on onto the next step
we add the new state array as an xor
with the round key of the particular
iteration
whatever state array we receive here it
becomes an output for this particular
round
now since this is the first round of the
entire encryption process the state
array that we receive is passed off as
an input to the new round
we repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text
once the final state array can be
denoted in the hexadecimal format this
becomes our final ciphertext that we can
use for transferring information from
the sender and receiver
let's take a look at the applications of
aes in this work
aes finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients
highly secure mechanisms like wpa and
wpa2 psk are extensively used in
securing wi-fi endpoints with the help
of rindial's algorithm
it also helps in ssl tls encryption that
is instrumental in encrypting our
internet browser sessions
aes works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for communication
aes is also prevalent in general file
encryption of various formats ranging
from critical documents to the media
files
having a large key allows people to
encrypt media and decrypt data with
maximum security possible
aes is also used for processor security
in hardware appliances to prevent
machine hijacking among other things
as a direct successor to the des
algorithm there are some aspects that
aes provides an immediate advantage in
let's take a look
when it comes to key length the biggest
flaw in ds algorithm was its small
length was easily vulnerable by today's
standards
aes has managed to nab up 128 192 and
256 bit key lens to bolster the security
further
the block size is also larger in aes
leading to more complexity of the
algorithm
the number of rounds in des is fixed
irrespective of the plain text being
used
in aes the number of round depends on
the key length that is being used for
the particular iteration thereby
providing more randomness and complexity
in the algorithm
the des algorithm is considered to be
simpler than aes even though aes beats
des when it comes to relative speed of
encryption and decryption
this makes advanced encryption standard
much more streamlined to be deployed in
frameworks and systems worldwide when it
compares to the data encryption standard
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
with the decline of symmetric encryption
algorithms of private message encryption
new cypher suits came into light
the glaring issue with symmetric
algorithms was key exchange
having to pass secret keys is a risk on
its own right
and that we were unable to solve in a
lot of scenarios
thankfully dsl algorithm has managed to
solve this problem
the use cases for this cipher is rather
niche but crucial nonetheless
let's understand what digital signatures
are before moving on to the algorithm
the objective of digital signatures is
to authenticate and verify documents and
data
this is necessary to avoid tampering and
digital modification or forgery of any
kind during the transmission of official
documents
they work on the public key cryptography
architecture with one exception
typically an asymmetric key system
encrypts using a public key and decrypts
the private key
for digital signatures however the
reverse is true
the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key
because the keys are inked together
decoding it with the public key verifies
that the proper private key was used to
sign the document therefore verifying
the signature's provenance
let's go through each step to understand
the procedure thoroughly
in step 1 we have m which is the
original plain text message
and it is passed on to a hash function
denoted by h
to create a digest
next it bundles the message together
with the hash digest and encrypts it
using the sender's private key
it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender's public key
once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function h
hash to generate a similar digest
it compares the newly generated hash
with the bundled hash value received
along with the message
if they match it verifies data integrity
in many instances they provide a layer
of validation and security messages
through non-secure channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender
digital signatures are equivalent to
traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type
digital signature schemes in the sense
used here are cryptographically based
and must be implemented properly to be
effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret
further some non-repudiation schemes
offer a timestamp for the digital
signature so that even if the private
key is exposed the signature is valid
to implement the concept of digital
signature in real world we have two
primary algorithms to follow the rsa
algorithm
and the dsa algorithm but the latter is
a topic of learning today
so let's go ahead and see what the
digital signature algorithm is supposed
to do
digital signature algorithm is fips
standard which is the federal
information processing standard for
digital signatures
it was proposed in 1991 and globally
standardized in 1994 by the national
institute of standards and technology
also known as the nist
it functions on the framework of modular
exponential and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute system
unlike dsa most signature types are
generated by signing message digest with
the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data
since just the message digest is signed
the signature is generally much smaller
compared to the data that was saying
as a result digital signatures impose
less load on processors at the time of
signing execution and they use small
volumes of bandwidth
dsa on the other hand does not encrypt
message digest using private key or dkip
message digest using public key instead
it uses mathematical functions to create
a digital signature consisting of two
160 bit numbers which are originated
from the message digest and the private
key
dc's make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with rsa
dsa also provides three benefits which
is the message authentication integrity
verification and non-repudiation
in the image we can see the entire
process of dsf validation a plain text
message is passed on to a hash function
where the digest is generated which is
passed on to a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g
of random variable k
and the private key of the sender
the outputs are then bundled onto a
single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver
the two outputs we receive from the
signing functions are the two 160 bit
numbers denoted by s and r
on the receiver end we pass the plain
text through the same hash function to
regenerate the message digest
it is passed on to verification function
which has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender global variable
g and snr received from the sender
the value generated by the function is
then compared to r
if they match then the verification
process is complete and data integrity
is verified
this was an overview of the way the dsa
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next section
we have three phases here the first of
which is key generation
to generate the keys we need some
prerequisites
we'd select a queue which becomes a
prime divisor we select a prime number p
such that p minus one mod q equal to
zero
we also select a random integer g which
must satisfy the two formulas being
mentioned on the screen right now
once these values are selected we can go
ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by x and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of 0 and the value
of q
the public key can be calculated as y
equal to g to the power x mod p
where y stands for the public key
the private key can then be packaged as
a bundle which comprises of values of p
q g and x
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p
q
g and y
once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this generation
repeat
once the keys are generated we can start
generating the signature
the message is passed through a hash
function to generate the digest h first
we can choose any random integer k which
falls under the bracket of 0 and q
to calculate the first 160 bit number of
our signing function of r we use the
formula g to the power k mod p into mod
cube
similarly to calculate the value of the
second output that is s we use the
following formula that is shown on the
screen
the signature can then be packaged as a
bundle having r and s
this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver
now with the third phase we have to
verify the signature
we first calculate the message i just
received in the bundle by passing it to
the same hash function
we calculate the value of w
u1
and u2 using the formulas shown on the
screen
we have to calculate a verification
component which is then to be compared
with the value of r being sent by the
sender this verification component can
be calculated using the following
formula
once calculated this can be compared
with the value of r if the values match
then the signature verification is
successful and the entire process is
complete starting from key generation to
the signature generation all the way up
to the verification of the signature
with so many steps to follow we are
bound to have a few advantages to boot
this and we would be right to think so
dsa is highly robust in the security and
stability aspect when compared to
alternative signature verification
algorithms
we have a few other ciphers that aim to
achieve the simplicity and the
flexibility of dsa but it has been a
tough ask for all the other suits
the key generation is much faster when
compared to the rsa algorithm and such
while the actual encryption and
decryption process may falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of frameworks
dsa requires less storage space to work
its entire cycle
in contrast its direct correspondent
that is rsa algorithm needs a certain
amount of computational and storage
space to function efficiently this is
not the case with dsm which has been
optimized to work with weaker hardware
and lesser resources
the dsa is patented but nist has made
this pattern available worldwide royalty
free
a draft version of the speculation
fips1865
indicates that dsa will no longer be
approved for digital signature
generation but it may be used to verify
signatures generated prior to the
implementation date of that standard the
rsa algorithm can be used for general
data encryption and decryption as well
functioning on a similar public key
cryptography architecture it is seen as
a more complex solution to bolster
security so let's go ahead and see what
the rsa algorithm is supposed to do
the rsa algorithm is a public key
signature algorithm developed by ron
rivest adish sameer and leonard edelman
the paper was first published in 1977
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand brute force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment rsa can also encrypt and
decrypt general information to securely
exchange data along with handling
digital signature verification
let us understand how it achieved this
we take our plain text message m we pass
it through a hash function to generate
the digest h which is then encrypted
using the sender's private key
this is appended to the original plain
text message and sent over to the
receiver
once the receiver receives the bundle we
can pass the plain text message to the
same hash function to generate a digest
and the ciphertext can be decrypted
using the public key of the sender the
remaining hashes are compared if the
values match then the data integrity is
verified and the sender is authenticated
apart from digital signatures the main
case of rsa is encryption and decryption
of private information before being
transmitted across communication
challenge
this is where the data encryption comes
into play when using rsa for encryption
and decryption of general data it
reverses the key set usage
unlike signature verification it
receives the receiver's public key to
encrypt the data and uses the receiver's
private key in decrypting the data
thus there is no need to exchange any
keys in this scenario there are two
broad components when it comes to rsa
cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for
encrypting and decrypting the data
the second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the ciphertext
you will now understand each of these
steps in a next subtopic
keeping the previous two concepts in
mind let us go ahead and see how the
entire process works starting from
creating the keeper to encrypting and
decrypting the information
you need to generate the public and
private keys before running the
functions to generate cipher text and
plain text they use certain variables
and parameters all of which are
explained
we first used two large prime numbers
which can be denoted by p and q
we can compute the value of n as n equal
to p into q and compute the value of z
as p minus 1 into q minus 1.
a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number d is also selected at random
following the formula e d mod j equal to
1 and it can be calculated with the
formula given below
the public key is then packaged as a
bundle with n and e and the private key
is packaged as a bundle using n and d
this sums up the key generation process
for the encryption and decryption
function we use the formula c
and m
the ciphertext can be calculated as c
equal to m to the power e mod n and the
plaintext can be calculated from the
ciphertext as c power d mod n
when it comes to a data encryption
example
let's take p and q as 7 and 13.
the value of n can be calculated as 91.
if we select the value of e to be 5 it
satisfy all the criteria that we needed
to
the value of d can be calculated using
the following function which gives it as
29 the public key can then be packaged
as 91 comma 5 and the private key can
then be packaged as 91 comma 29.
the plain text if it is 10 which is gray
noted by m
ciphertext can be calculated to the
formula c equal to m to the power e mod
n which gives us 82.
if somebody receives this cipher text
they can calculate the plain text using
the formula c to the part d mod n which
gives us the value of 10 as selected as
our plain text
we can now look at the factors that make
the rsa algorithm stand out versus its
competitors in the advantageous topics
of this lesson
rsa encryption depends on using the
receiver's public key so that you don't
have to share any secret key to receive
the messages from others
this was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography structure
since the key pairs are related to each
other a receiver cannot intercept the
message since they didn't have the
correct private keys to decrypt the
information
if a public key can decrypt the
information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private anymore
the encryption process is faster than
that of the dsa algorithm
even if the key generation is slower in
rsa many systems across the world tend
to reuse the same keys so that they can
spend less time in key generation and
more time on actual cipher text
management
data will be tamper proof in transit
since meddling with the data will alter
the usage of the keys
the private key won't be able to decrypt
the information hence alerting the
receiver of any kind of manipulation in
between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
transit the cases of which are rather
low md5 algorithm was one of the first
hashing algorithms to take the global
stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 still
remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments
the md5 hashing algorithm is a one-way
cryptographic functions that accepts a
message of any length as input and it
returns as output a fixed length digest
value to be used for authenticating the
original messages
the digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input
the md5 hash function was originally
designed for use as a secure
cryptographic hash algorithm to
authenticate digital signatures
md5 has also been depreciated for uses
other than as a non-cryptographic
checksum to verify data integrity and
detect unintentional data corruption
ronald rivest founder of rsa data
security and institute professor at mit
designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the md4
as already iterated before the process
is straightforward we pass our plain
text message to the md5 hash functions
which in turn performs certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data
the 128-bit digest received from this is
going to be radically different from the
plain text
the goal of any message digest function
is to produce digests that appear to be
random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash functions should meet
two requirements first that it is
impossible for an attacker to generate a
message that matches a specific hash
value and second that it is impossible
for an attacker to create two messages
that produce the same hash value
even a slight change in the plain text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which take place when two
different plaintexts have the same
digest
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the rises
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when we receive the input string we have
to make sure the size is 64 bit short of
a multiple of 512.
when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters
this prepares the string to have a
length of just 64 bits less than any
multiple of 512
here on out we can proceed on to the
next step where we have to pad the
length bits
initially in the first step we appended
the message in such a way that the total
length of the bits in the message was 64
bit short of any multiple of 512
now we add the length bits in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message is perfectly a multiple of 512.
that means 64-bit lens to be precise are
added to the message our final string to
be hashed is now a definite multiple of
512
the next step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer
the entire hashing plain text is now
broken down into 512 bit blocks
there are four buffers or registers that
are of 32 bits each named a b c and d
these are the four words that are going
to store the values of each of these sub
blocks
the first iteration to follow these
registers will have fixed hexadecimal
values as shown on the screen below
once these values are initial
of these 512 blocks we can divide each
of them into 16 further sub blocks of 32
bits each
for each of these sub blocks we run four
rounds of operations having the four
buffer variables a b c and d
these rounds require the other constant
variables as well which differ with each
round of operation
the constant values are stored in a
random array of 64 elements
since each 32-bit sub-block is run 4
times 16 such sub-blocks equal 64
constant values needed for a single
block iteration
the sub-blocks can be denoted by the
alphabet m and the constant values are
denoted by the alphabet t
coming to the actual round of operation
we see our four buffers which already
have pre-initialized values for the
first iteration
at the very beginning the values of
buffers b c and d are passed on to a
non-linear logarithmic function
the formula behind this function changes
by the particular round being worked on
as we shall see later in this video
once the output is calculated it is
added to the raw value stored in buffer
a
the output of this addition is added to
the particular 32-bit sub-block using
which we are running the four operations
the output of this requisite function
then needs to be added to a constant
value derived from the constant array k
since we have four different elements in
the array
repeat
since we have 64 different elements in
the array we can use a distinct element
for each iteration of a particular block
the next step involves a circular shift
that increases the complexity of the
hash algorithm and is necessary to
create a unique digest for each
individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer b
the final output is now stored in the
second buffer of b of the output
register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in c
value of c gets stored in d and the
value of d in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this sub block the values of a b c d
are moved on as input to the next sub
block
once all 16 sub-blocks are completed the
final register value is saved and the
next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5 algorithm
regarding the non-linear process
mentioned in the first step the formula
changes for each round it's being run on
this is done to maintain the
computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure
the formula for each of the four rounds
uses the same parameters that is b c and
d to generate a single output the
formulas being used are shown on the
screen right now
algorithm
unlike the latest hash algorithm
families a 32-bit digest is relatively
easier to compare when verifying the
digest
they don't consume a noticeable amount
of disk storage and are comparatively
easier to remember and reiterate
passwords need not be stored in plain
text format making them accessible for
hackers and malicious actors
when using digest the database security
also gets a boost since the size of all
the hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which should
be the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays
a relatively low memory footprint is
necessary when it comes to integrating
multiple services into the same
framework without a cpu overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string
this helps in creating a low requirement
for computational power and is much
easier to run on older hardware which is
pretty common in server farms around the
world
we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
transit
once the hashes match file integrity
checks are valid and we can avoid data
corruption
hash functions will always give the same
output for the similar input
irrespective of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring that the data
hasn't been tampered with on route to
the receiver of the message
we use our wi-fi every day for work and
we use the internet for entertainment
and communication
the dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades
a big portion of this belongs to
ensuring secure channels of
communication and data transmission
the secure hash algorithm are a family
of cryptographic hash functions that are
published by the national institute of
standards and technology along with the
nsa
it was passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as fips
it has four different families of hash
functions
ssj0 is a 160 bit hash function
published in 1993 and it was closed down
later after an undisclosed significant
flaw
sha-1 is also a 160 bit hash function
which resembles the earlier md5
algorithm this was designed by the nsa
to be a part of the digital signature
algorithm
sga 2 is a family of two similar hash
functions with different block sizes
known as the sha-256 and the sha-512
they differ in the word size
ssh-256 uses 32-bit words while sha-512
uses 64-bit words
ssj3 is a hash function properly known
as kcac it was chosen in 2012 after a
public competition among non-nsa
designers
it supports the same hash lengths as
http2 and its internal structure differs
significantly from the rest of the sha
family
as we have already iterated the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the sha hash function which
in turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 160 bit digest received
from this is going to be radically
different from the plain text
the goal of any hash function is to
produce digests that appear to be random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash function should meet two
requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value
and second it should be impossible for
an attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plain text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which takes place when two
different plane tests have the same
digest the sha family functions have
some characteristics that they need to
follow while generating the digest
let's go through a few of them
the length of the clear text should be
less than 2 to the power 64 bits in the
case of sha 1 and s h 256
this is essential to keep the plain text
compatible with the hash function and
the size needs to be in comparison area
to keep the digest as random as possible
the length of the hash digest should be
256 bits in the sha-256 algorithm 512
bits in the sha 512 algorithm and so on
bigger digest usually suggests
significantly more calculations at the
cost of speed and space
we typically go for the longest digest
to bolster security but there must be a
definite balance between the speed and
security of a hash function
by design all hash function of the sha
512 she-256
are irreversible
you should neither get a plain text when
you have the digest beforehand
nor should the digest provide the
original value when you pass it through
the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance
this is done to reduce the chance of
brute force attacks
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the sha algorithm
works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when you receive the input string you
have to make sure the size is 64 bit
short of a multiple of 512.
when it comes to padding the bits you
must add one first followed by the
remaining zeroes to round out the extra
characters
this prepares our string to have a
length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of 512
here on out we can proceed to the next
step where we have to pad the length
bits
initially in the first step we appended
the message in such a way that the total
number of bits in the message was 64 bit
short from becoming a multiple of 512.
now we add the length of bits in such a
way that the total number of bits in the
message is a perfect multiple of 512
that means 64 bits plus the length of
the original message becomes a multiple
of 512 this becomes a final string that
needs to be hashed
in the next step we have to initialize
this chaining variables
the entire plain text message can now be
broken down into blocks of 512 bits each
unlike other hash algorithms like md5
which use 4 registers or buffers sha
family use 5 buffers of 32 bits each
they are named a b c d and e these
registers go through multiple rounds of
operation but the first iteration has
fixed hexadecimal values as can be seen
in the screen
moving on we have to process each of the
512-bit blocks by breaking each of them
into 16 sub-blocks of 32 bits each
each of them goes through 4 rounds of
operation that use the entire register
and have the 512 bit block along with
the constant array out of those 4 rounds
each round has 20 iterations so in
general we have 80 rounds sum total
the constant value of k is an array of
80 elements
of those 80 16 elements are being used
each round so that comes out to 80
rounds for each of those elements
the value of t differs by the number of
rounds as can be seen in the table below
a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration
the formula can be a b c d e register is
equal to e plus a non-linear process p
along with a circular shift of a plus wt
plus kt
in this formula abcd is the register
value of the chaining variables as we
discussed before
p is the logical process which has a
different formula for each round
s5 is a circular shift by 5 bits
and wt is a 32-bit string derived from
the existing sub-block this can be
calculated depending on the iteration at
hand
kt signifies a single element of the 80
character element array which changes
depending on the particular round at
hand
for the values of wt the first 16 values
are the same as that of the sub blocks
so there is no extra calculation needed
for the next 64 elements the value of wt
can be calculated as shown in the
formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the 5 words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the output
next we use a non-linear process p that
changes depending on the round and uses
the values of b c and d as input
whatever output is generated from the
non-linear process it is added with the
value of the e register
next the value of a is circular shifted
by 5 bits and is added with the output
generated in the previous step
the next step is adding the value of wt
and the constant element of kt the
current output is then stored in the
register a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each sub
block in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the sub
blocks are joined together to form the
single ciphertext message we will have
our hashed output regarding the
non-linear process p that uses the
values of b c and d as input
the formula changes every round to
maintain a complexity of the program
that can withstand brute force attacks
depending on the round the values are
passed through a logical operation which
is then added with the values of wt kt
and so on now that we understand how to
get our hash digest from the plain text
let us learn about the advantages we
obtain when using the sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text format
digital signatures follow asymmetric
encryption methodology to verify the
authenticity of a document or a file
hash algorithms like ssh 256 and the
industry standard sha 512 go a long way
in ensuring the verification of
signatures
passwords need not be stored in a plain
text format which makes them accessible
to hackers and other malicious actors
when using digest the database security
also gets a boost since the size of all
hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hash values with no way to regenerate
the plain text
in this case the plain text would be
user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers
the ssl handshake is a crucial segment
of the web browsing sessions and it's
done using sha functions
it consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection
it relies on a combination of symmetric
and asymmetric algorithms which ensure
the confidentiality of the data
transmitted between a web server and a
web client like the browsers
you can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
transit
once the hashes match file integrity
checks are valid and data corruption is
avoided
hash functions will always give the same
output for the same input irrespective
of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring that the data
hasn't been tampered with on route to
the receiver of the message with every
passing year a dependence on digital
technology increases tenfold we book
transport via mobiles and shop clothes
on our laptops
among all these nitty-gritty day-to-day
activities information such as payment
authentication personal data and private
credentials are transported over the
internet with various website partners
with this reliance on the internet as
gradual
its impact has been every bit as
definite
this statistic represents the daily time
spent online by internet users worldwide
starting from 2011 all the way up to
2021 sorted by device
according to zenith optimidia
in 2018 the average daily minutes of
desktop internet consumption per capita
amounted to 39 minutes and it is slowly
projected to decline until 2020.
however the daily mobile internet
consumption is set to increase to 155
minutes in 2021.
if our current lifestyle is any
indication of the future these
statistics are just a window into what
is going to be a future full of
artificial intelligence and its
derivatives
as observed by researchers around the
world this level of dependability has
made us vulnerable to the worst of the
internet
according to the forbes magazine in 2019
the cumulative damage and cost of cyber
effect are far more significant than
those inflicted by natural disasters in
a year
every 11 seconds a business falls victim
to a ransomware attack
the average cost of a data breach in
2020 is 3.86 million dollars
the huge increase in cyber crimes is a
major contributor to the 12 annual
growth rate of cybersecurity spending
the united states has the world's
highest average data breach crossed at
6.84 million dollars as per 2020 records
opportunities breed innovation and this
has been observed in the cyber security
domain as well
to safeguard against such threats the
ssl protocol was developed
let us learn about the ssl protocol
first
ssl or secure sockets layer is an
encryption based internet security
protocol
it was first developed by netscape in
1995 for the purpose of ensuring privacy
authentication and data integrity in
internet communication
ssl is the predecessor to the modern tls
encryption news today
attacks is a cryptographic layer
protocol that provides privacy and
security to communication between a
client and a web server
a website that implements ssl
authentication has https in its url
instead of http
in order to provide a high degree of
privacy ssl encrypts data that is
transmitted across the web this means
that anyone who tries to intercept this
data will only see a garbled mix of
characters that is nearly impossible to
decrypt
ssl initiates an authentication process
called a handshake between two
communicating devices to ensure that
both of them are really who they claim
to be
ssl also digitally signs data in order
to provide data integrity
the internet we use today follows an osi
model or even systems interconnections
model it is a priority system that
characterizes and standardizes the
communication on the internet among its
multiple layers the ssl layer functions
between the application layer
and the transport layer
the application layer provides services
for an application to ensure that
effective communication with another
applic program is possible
the transport layer is responsible for
error-free end-to-end delivery of data
from the source host to the destination
host
since the ssl protocol functions in
between these two layers the data is
encrypted and is authenticated after
being passed through the application and
before it is transmitted over the
network
to further understand this priority
table let us look at the table of how it
works
hypertext transfer protocol http is an
application layer protocol that is used
for transmitting information between
computers on the world wide web
http is based on a request response
standard between a client and server
once the data is ready to be shared we
can pass it on to the ssl layers
as you can notice the protocol being
used right now is http it signifies that
the data is unencrypted and hence
vulnerable to malicious attacks
the data is then passed on to the ssl
where we have the record protocol for
the confidentiality protection and the
handshake protocol for the
authentication of client and server the
sub protocols of the ssl will be later
discussed in detail
after the data is encrypted and ready to
be transmitted it is moved on to the
transport layer where we use the tcp
packets to send their data along to the
internet layer and from that point
forward the data can move to its
destination using the internet protocol
or ip addressing tables
with so many sub-protocols and
sub-variants of the ssl protocol the
work is divided into multiple layers and
aspects
let's have a look at some of the ways
the ssl layer make the internet safe and
secure
for server authentication the client
uses the server's public key to encrypt
the data which is used to complete the
secret key
the server can generate the secret key
only if it can decrypt the information
with the correct private key
for client authentication the server
uses the public key in the client
certificate
if any of the authentication steps fail
the handshake fails and the session
terminates
this exchange of digital certificates
during the ssl handshake is a part of
the authentication process
ssl provides data integrity by
calculating a message digest or a hash
use of ssl does ensure integrity
provided that the cipher spec in your
channel definition uses a hash algorithm
in the ssl record protocol the hash
value is generated for the data to be
transmitted hence providing a necessary
way to verify data corruption
ssl uses a combination of symmetric and
asymmetric encryption to ensure message
privacy
during the ssl handshake the ssl client
and server agree to an encryption
algorithm and a shared secret key is
used for that particular session
all the messages transmitted between the
client and server are then encrypted
using the same algorithm and key that
ensure that the message will remain
private even if it is intercepted
regarding the multiple layers in the ssl
protocol we have many sub protocols that
ensure the three protection aspects of
security let us learn more about these
the ssl record protocol provides two
services to the ssl connection
confidentiality and message integrity
in ssl record protocol the data is
divided into fragments
the fragment comprises of the encrypted
sha code and the md5 code after the
encryption of the data is done the last
ssl header is also appended to the data
the handshake protocol is used to
establish sessions this protocol allows
the client and server to authenticate
each other by sending a series of
messages
handshake protocol uses four phase
system to complete its cycle
in phase 1 both the client and server
send hello packets to each other
in phase 2 they exchange the
certificates with the correct private
and public keys
in phase 3 they reply to each other with
the encryption algorithms and the secret
keys while in phase 4 the handshake is
completed
for the chain cipher spec protocol we
use a part of the ssl record protocol
unless handshake is completed the ssl
record output will be in a pending state
after handshake the pending state is
converted into a current state
the chain cipher protocol consists of a
single message which is of one byte
inlet and can hold only one value
the ssl alert protocol is used to convey
ssl related alerts to the peer entity
each message in this protocol contains
only two bytes let's see how the ssl
handshake works in a step-by-step format
we have divided the handshake into four
distinct phases
in phase one the client and server get
acquainted with the hello signal message
from each side
the client sends the ssl version cipher
suit and the session id
the server returns an encryption
algorithm which is chosen from the
cipher suit and a compression algorithm
which is sent from the client hello
signal each
this helps in setting up a common
encryption algorithm and a common hash
value to be used throughout the
handshake process
in phase 2
the server sends it authentication
certificate and requests for client
authentication
the server also sends its public
encryption key
and the phrase with the server hello
done message
once the server sends its public key the
client can use it to encrypt its own
private key which will be later used to
encrypt the data being exchanged between
the client and a server
in phase 3
the client sends its authentication
certificate after verifying the server
with the respective certificate
authorities
the client now send a private key which
is encrypted using the server's
previously sent public key
in phase 4 the client sends the status
of the cipher functions along with a
finished message to end the handshake
from its side
the server also sends the status of the
cipher algorithm and ends with a
finished signal
the data is now encrypted with a
symmetric key client sent in phase three
with the end of phase four
authentication is complete and the ssl
handshake has maintained the
authenticity of the entire session
between the client and server
to reiterate the entire process
let's go through each step one more time
the client sends a hello request to the
server
the server responds with its own hello
message and sends the server
authentication certificate for
verification
at this point the server's hello signal
is complete
the client exchanges a secret key with
the server to encrypt the data and the
cipher spec parameters are changed
accordingly
the client has now finished its own
handshake activities
the server uses the secret key provided
by the client to encrypt the data and
alters its own cipher spec parameters as
a final step before it sends a finished
signal at this point the ssl handshake
is complete with an encryption algorithm
and a secure data channel to transmit
information
with ssl protocol being developed in the
early 90s it was bound to be a little
underpowered when pitted against the
current day computers and hackers
let's see its future implications and
replacements
ssl encryption has been depreciated now
with its version 2 and version 3 being
dropped by the internet engineering task
force in 2011 and 2015 respectively
there had been far too many security
vulnerabilities to carry on official
activities during the ssl prayer to
further enhance the security the
transport layer security or tls has been
developed as a successor to the ssl
protocol
tls is a proposed ietf standard first
developed in 1999 and the current
version is tls 1.3 which was defined in
august 2018.
even though a major part of the internet
is still using tls 1.2 as a safety net
the transition to the latest version
should be completed before any security
deficiencies are exploited a significant
portion of today's internet is encrypted
using secret encryption keys and for
good reason apart from bolstering
security encrypting communication
channels maintain both the
confidentiality and the integrity of the
data being transmitted
the exchange of these secret keys had
always been an arduous task irrespective
of the scope of operation
since the globally standardized
symmetric encryption had seen a lot of
application in the it industry
exchanging the encryption and decryption
key needed a safe approach
to highlight the issue at hand let's
take a look at henry and stella
both our users want to communicate with
each other in a safe and secure manner
while using encrypted messages
to move forward with the system though
the need to have a secret key that can
both encrypt and decrypt the message
being transmitted
the most glaring issue here is the
inability to exchange the specific key
before they start communicating
since they don't have a secure channel
anyone looking at the communication
channel can easily intercept this key if
the key is intercepted all the messages
that are exchanged between henry and
stella can easily be read by the
malicious actors since they already have
the decryption key this is where the
diffie-hellman key exchange algorithm
comes into play
it made the process much more
streamlined and more secure let's start
by learning a bit more about this
exchange process
diffie-hellman algorithm is a method for
securely exchanging cryptography keys
over insecure channels without
compromising the security and integrity
of the data transmission
it was developed and published in 1976
by martin hellman and whitfield defe
the main usp of this algorithm was the
ability to exchange such critical crees
over insecure networks
once the keys are exchanged without any
malicious actors they can be used to
transfer encrypted data and thereby
establish a secure channel for
communication
until we receive the asymmetric
encryption algorithms that never relied
on any category of key exchange
symmetric encryption was the only way to
communicate securely
a secure method to exchange the private
keys for this brand of cryptography was
much needed
very important part of how the diffi
helmet exchange works at the mechanism
behind one way functions where the
output should not be able to be deduced
back to the original input
to better understand how the one-way
functions work let's take a look at this
exchange process using color theory
initially both the users must have a
private color decided on their own and
it should not be made public even to the
user with whom we'll be exchanging keys
let's say the first user has a private
color as red and the second user has the
private color as blue
next they should be having a common
public color which can be decided over
insecure channels if need be
in this case we are choosing this common
color to be yellow in the next step both
users have to mix their private colors
and the publicly decided common color
after mixing you are going to get a new
color mixture with each of the users
once we receive a new mixture for each
user this mixture is then sent to each
other now this is done over an insecure
channel which means this communication
can easily be intercepted by any
malicious actors who are listening on to
the channel
at this point of time even if the
mixtures are exchanged the hackers have
only that the mixtures they do not
possess the private colors of both users
after the mixtures are received
they are supposed to mix their own
private color with the received mixture
of the opposite user once the colors are
mixed they will both get a single color
which will be selected as the final
secret color or it can be a final secret
key
now even though this entire
communication took place over an
insecure channel because of the
inability of the hacker to receive the
private colors of both users he has no
idea that the secret color in the case
of transmission is actually brown and
not green or yellow which he intercepted
during the transmission this is how the
one way functions work and the keys can
be exchanged over insecure channels
without compromising on the privacy now
that we understand the theory and the
root logic behind this exchange
let us learn more about the mathematical
side of the diffie-hellman key exchange
in our next section
we can break down the entire key
exchange process into three distinct
steps
step one is choosing q and alpha
first we choose a prime number q which
will stay consistent throughout the
process
once we have selected q we need to
select a primitive root of q and denote
it by the symbol alpha
this alpha will be a primitive root
modulo of q if every number co prime to
q is congruent to the power of alpha mod
q
now to satisfy the primitive root
requirement of a prime number the values
of alpha mod q alpha square mod q all
the way up to alpha q minus 1 mod q must
all follow
this formula where it should always be
less than q which has the range of
ranging from 1 up to q minus 1.
if this condition is satisfied alpha can
be selected as a primitive root for q
moving on to step two we have a driving
the key pair process
let's say for the first user we assume
the private key to be denoted by x a
where the xa's value should always be
less than q
after we decide on the private key the
public key which will be denoted by y a
can be calculated using the formula
alpha to the power x a mod q
now that we have both the private key
and the public key settle the key pair
of the first user becomes xa and ya
similarly for the second user we let's
say the private key is supposed to be xb
which must also be less than q the
public key of the second user can also
be calculated using the formula
alpha to the power xb mod q
similar to the first user the key pair
will have both the private key and
public key which becomes xb and yb
finally in step 3 we have the key
generation steps
we already have the parameters for the
first user which will be his private key
the receiver's public key and the value
of q which will stay constant to
calculate the secret key or the secret
color as denoted by brown in the color
theory the formula we're going to use is
yb to the power xa mod q
for the second user we're going to use a
similar formula but with slightly
different parameters
it will be the private key of the user
public key of the other user and the
value of q
the formula will be similar in the phase
of y a to the power x b mod q
to satisfy the entire diffie-hellman key
exchange process both these generated k
value must be equal to successfully
generate the key these values should be
equal
the key generated will be used to
encrypt the messages while being
transmitted over insecure channels as
denoted by the brown color
to get a more clear idea of how it is
going to work we can take a real world
example with mathematical values to
prove this theory
in step 1 we have to choose q and alpha
so let's say if we choose a prime number
q to be 17
in choosing alpha which will be the
primitive root of q we have decided
we're going to take alpha as 3
now to satisfy the condition of the
primitive root we can check that three
mod 17 which is 3 3 square merc 17 9 and
all the way up to 3 power 16 mod 17 they
all fall below 70. so it satisfy the
condition to be a primitive root of the
prime number 17.
in step 2 we need to settle on the
private and the public key
for the first user the private key which
will be considered as xa let's say we
decided to be 15.
now that we have the value of the
private key settled at 15 we can
calculate the public key with the
formula 3 power 15 mod 17 which is
supposedly alpha to the power xa mod q
the value becomes 6. so our key pair
becomes 15 and 6 which is the private
key and the public key of the first user
for the second user let's consider the
private key xb to b13
the public key can then be calculated
this formula 3 to the power 13 mod 17
which has the value of 12.
so in the second user's case the key
pair can be 13 and 12.
in step three which is the key
generation we already have the requisite
parameters for both users
to calculate the secret key on the first
user we're going to use the formula of k
equal to 12 power 15 mod 17 which gives
the output as 10.
similarly for second user we're going to
calculate the secret key using the
formula 6 to the power 13 mod 17 which
gives the value as 10.
now that we have both values of k at 10
this becomes our n secret encryption and
decryption key
both users can encrypt the messages with
this value of k before transmitting the
data and the receiver can generate the
key on their site too as seen in this
video
so unless anyone has the secret key as a
supplement to the publicly decided key
no amount of hacking can break the
secure channel
thankfully this key exchange process was
very well received and is being used
nowadays in a lot of places
let's read about some of these occasions
the public key infrastructure or pki is
a set of tools and rules to enforce
public key cryptography with multiple
entities it governs the issuance of
digital certificates around the internet
to maintain data confidentiality
our internet browsers are authenticated
with website servers using an ssl or tls
certificate and many encryption keys in
between
this is only possible due to this
diffie-hellman key exchange algorithm
which enables the secure exchange of
cryptographic entities over all channels
we also have secure shell access or ssh
for short it is a cryptographic protocol
used to access system terminals from a
third party appliance or application
the diffie helmet algorithm helps in
exchanging the keys between both systems
so that remote access can be enabled
here we will focus on the popular
cryptography questions that can be asked
in a cyber security interview
our experienced instructor bipin will
take you through these questions so
let's get started the first question
define cryptography encryption and
decryption
now cryptography
is used by security professionals to
scramble data
into non-readable format
which is used in securing that
information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like a unreadable
format now if you look at this word that
it has been scrambled into it would be
very difficult
for a human to figure out
what the actual word was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where we have made a
shift of the alphabet where we have
added two alphabets the current one so c
plus two becomes e
o plus two becomes q m plus 2 becomes o
so we have done a shift of 2 and thus
the key over here for this
algorithm
is the alphabet plus 2. so any person
who figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text
the fact of scrambling a readable text
data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key is what
cryptography is all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is uh replacing the alphabet and taking
it further back by two characters so e
minus two becomes c q minus two becomes
o o minus two becomes m and so on so
forth so anybody who knows this key uh
the shift key
anybody will able to
decrypt this particular character so
this depends on the user if i want to
utilize alphabet plus five then the
spacing the shifting of that character
will be the fifth character from that
particular character
and so on so forth
the next question what is the difference
between cipher text and clear text
cipher text refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be
however if the moment we encrypt it that
means we scramble it into unreadable
text by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the english language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block cipher
this refers to the method of encrypting
the plain message block by block the
plain message is broken down into fixed
size blocks and then encrypted now a
block cipher is normally used for data
that is stored so a data that is stored
on a hard disk and we want to encrypt
that data that is known as block
encryption or a block cipher so a block
cipher is an algorithm
that will allow you to encrypt data that
is stored onto a hard disk
so in this example we've got
a plain text which is 64 bits in size
and we have
added a layer of encryption to it so
plain text plus the key that we have
studied in the previous questions and
then the scrambled data out of it which
is unreadable and thus encrypted then
the next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private
so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques
which are standardized in nature
and are globally accepted which allow us
to use digital certificates to encrypt
data and decrypt the data
at the other end we use asymmetric
encryption over here which means that we
use two keys one is a public key to
encrypt and the private key to decrypt
the other part of your encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
uh like i said we have standardized that
so instead in the standardization part
of it these are the various players that
have been defined in the public key
infrastructure the first is this
user or the sender in the scenario the
one who requires this digital signature
to digitally sign a particular
transaction or a communication a
registration authority with whom they
are going to register for that
particular key the certification
authority who issues that key the
verification of the authority who
validates the
key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized
a sender or the user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration authority the registration
authority would validate the
genuinely of the user so they might do
some
identity verification or uh
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the person
and they have validated the information
they will then send the request to the
certification authority stating that the
sender has been validated and we can and
the certification authority can issue
the digital certificate to the
particular user
they will send the public key to the
sender which will be utilized by the
sender for further transactions so when
the sender
is going to sign some data and
wants to send it across to the recipient
they will use the public key to sign it
and send it across
the recipient will then validate with
the verification authority to see if the
data the sign data is correct or not now
while
the certification authority sends the
public key to the sender the
certification authority updates the
private key with the verification
authority so whatever is signed by the
sender
received by the recipient and they want
to validate it they will send it back to
the verification authority
the verification authority will validate
using the private key once the private
key is validated
it will then send the ok signal back to
the recipient thus allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the very fiction authority is not
able to validate the signature it will
then send a denial message back to the
recipient and the transaction will
not go through
so the pki enables trusted digital
identities for people so the pki grants
secure access to digital resources based
on the infrastructure that has been
created and the core of the pki is a
certification authority which ensures
that the trustworthiness of the digital
data is
ensured
so
going back to the previous slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the public key
infrastructure the certification
authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
authority is the one who validates that
digital certificate
moving on what is rsa
rsa is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for reverse
xiaomira and edelman now these are the
three people who have created this
algorithm rand rivest adhesive and
leonard edelman who are the inventors of
this technique it is a symmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas
asymmetric cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to rsa now rsa is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized uh
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what
rsa is it stands for
reverse xiaomi and edelman the three
creators of that particular algorithm
but there are a lot of alternatives to
this algorithm depending on how secure
you want that data to be
and some of them are listed here on your
screen duo security octa google
authenticator and lastpass lastpass is a
password manager
so is dual security google authenticator
is something that we all utilize it is
an application that we can download and
store on our mobile devices and we can
set that up to
authenticate ourselves with certain
portals so it issues a unique id to us
which once utilized will allow us access
to those particular portals octa is an
identity manager where you have created
different digital identities and you
have assigned them certain permissions
and based on your authentication
mechanisms octa will allow or disallow
access to those different applications
or different portals as you have
configured it so all four
are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to rsa
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
next question what are the prime
objectives of modern cryptography and
this is a very important question
because we've we've so far looked at
what cryptography is and what public key
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to uh
gain out of it so the main and the prime
objectives of modern cryptography are
as follows mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality
the second one is non-repudiation
third one is authenticity and the fourth
one is integrity
now if i go back to the first one
confidentiality uh that is where i want
to keep data confidential that means it
will only be visible to the authorized
users right so here i've
created a list of people who have deemed
as authorized users and have created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is
ensured so when we want to keep data
confidential we create a list of users
who we are going to allow access to
certain resources and we are going to
define what access controls are to be
utilized what access are allowed whether
they got an administrative access or
user level access and only those
authorized users are going to be
able to access this resources that is
how we maintain confidentiality
the next one is non-repudiation
non-reputation is the prevention of
denial of having been a part of a
particular transaction
so in the public key infrastructure that
we discussed where a digital signature
was utilized to sign a particular
transaction
and then sent to the recipient the
sender would not be able to deny of
having originated that transaction
because it was using their
digital certificate thus non-repudiation
comes into the picture uh one more
example that we can have here is uh on
our mobile phones when we use sms short
messaging service and we send a message
to
uh to another person the person when
they receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator
and thus the sender cannot
deny having sent that message the sender
at the same time can have a delivery
report sent to them
from that the message was delivered to
the inbox of the recipient and thus if
the recipient denies having received
that message the delivery report becomes
proof
of having
that message being delivered to their
inbox
thus both the parties cannot deny of
have a of being a part of that
particular transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned to a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
been a part of that transaction but
authenticity is the part where they try
to prove that they are who they claim to
be so if i am claiming a digital
identity
i have to prove that i am that person
who
i am trying to claim to be and an
example to that is when we go to our
gmail.com websites it first asks us what
is our username our username is normally
our email address which identifies the
account that we are trying to access
right so this account is confidential
because it is only authorized for a
particular person
and once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address that's
when the authentication part comes into
the picture where it asks for the
password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go on to the gmail.com type in a
password and then it figures out which
account we are talking about so the
first step is always the confidentiality
part where we identify which account we
are talking about and then we try to
authenticate as the owner of that
particular account by providing the
appropriate password to that account if
both of these match only then do we get
access to that account and
we are able to make uh whatever
transactions we want to make now when we
are making those transactions
non-reputation comes into the place
where all our activities also being
logged so we have identified our account
we have authenticated ourselves by
providing the password so the proof is
there that it is us who are trying to
access it
and then whatever activity we do send an
email receive an email delete something
attach something all of those activities
are logged
and stored as proof
of what actions have been done
so tomorrow if we deny having sent that
email gmail can still prove to us
through those logs that though that that
activity was done by us
and the fourth part is integrity which
ensures that the data received and sent
and
sent by the sender and received by the
recipient has not been modified while in
uh
motion
so the integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other uh entity and is still
trustworthy
so these are the four prime objectives
of modern cryptography once i have
scrambled that data
using
my public's uh signature it is only my
private signature that is going to
decrypt it right uh
using these mechanisms i will be able to
achieve all these four aspects
of cryptography and
security next question what is safer
now safer stands for secure and fast
encryption routine which is also a block
cipher as we have discussed previously
block cipher is a cipher that is used to
encrypt data that is stored so it has a
64-bit block size and byte oriented
algorithm
uh safer's encryption and decryption
procedures are highly secure this
technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment cards
so when you're using your
a digital payment gateway to make
transactions so you have you have gone
on to an online portal you want to
purchase a particular item
and then it takes you to another
payment gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your uh
expiry dates cvv information and then
the otp or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on pci dss which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards ensure that
certain protocols are utilized
to attain that level of security safer
is one of those block ciphers that is
used under the digital payment gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work
now we have already discussed this in
the previous diagrams
we have identified the key players the
certification authority the registration
authority the end user who requires the
digital certificate the validation
authority who's going to validate it and
then the
recipe and the end user with whom the
transaction is going to be
conducted so the first point here is uh
the request for the digital certificate
is said to the registration authority
they validate it and then they okay to
the certification authority who then
process the request and the digital
certificate is issued to the person who
has requested it
so when the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that
uh digital certificate to sign that
transaction with the end user the end
user validates that with the validation
authority and once validated the
transaction goes through
and now the last question what is the
blowfish algorithm it is a 64-bit
symmetric encryption algorithm so this
is an algorithm that uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret key is used to encrypt
and decrypt the messages here the
operations are based on exclusive ors
and additions to the on 32-bit words
the key has a maximum length of 448 bits
now this is a little bit technical uh
you might not want to go this technical
in an interview question you just need
to identify what the algorithm is used
for so whether it is a symmetric
algorithm which means it uses the same
key
or uh
a symmetric algorithm where it uses a
public key to encrypt and a private key
to decrypt
this the blowfish algorithm is just one
more algorithm which uses symmetric
encryption to encrypt and decrypt data
algorithms that we have seen rsa and
others that we have discussed as far as
the interview questions are concerned
what we need to remember is uh which
algorithms are symmetric which
algorithms are asymmetric what do
symmetric algorithms do and what do
unsymmetric uh symmetric algorithms do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers block ciphers are
utilized to encrypt data that is stored
stationary data data addressed and
stream ciphers are utilized for data in
motion while they're being streamed
so ssl and tls is another algorithm that
comes into the picture when you're
looking at streaming data
the world runs on data law
the internet houses are treasure club of
potentially harmful information from
basic shopping habits to private
financial transactions
all this data is carried over a network
of interconnected devices
during transit the data is as secure as
the mechanism responsible for its
transmission
it's in this phase that the most
corrupted data originates
it's paramount that the networks
carrying this data must be secured
against malicious hackers and harmful
attacks
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered in this video on network
security which is rising in popularity
and importance
we start by introducing the viewers to
network security and specific definition
we cover the working of network security
in the next section
then we have the different types of
network security followed by a small
introduction to transport and
application layer security and the
importance
next we cover the key tools in network
security the benefits and a live
demonstration of how nmap can scan posts
and aid in ethical hacking
so let's start with the first topic for
the day which is an introduction to
network security
network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network
it architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it
effective network security strategies
employ multiple lines of defense that
are scalable and automated each
defensive layer here enforces a set of
security policies which are determined
by the administrator beforehand
this aims at securing the
confidentiality and accessibility of the
data and the network
the every company or organization that
handles a large amount of data has a
degree of solutions against many cyber
threats the most basic example of
network security is password protection
it has the network the user chooses
recently network security has become the
central topic of cyber security with
many organizations involving
applications from people with skills in
this area
it is crucial for both personal and
professional networks most houses with
high speed internet have one or more
wireless routers which can be vulnerable
to attacks if they are not adequately
data loss theft and sabotage risk may be
decreased with the usage of a strong
network security system
the workstations are protected from
hazardous firewall thanks to network
security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over
and over
by dividing information into various
sections
encrypting these portions and
transferring them over separate pathways
network security infrastructure offers
multiple levels of protection to thwart
man in the middle attacks preventing
situations like eavesdropping among
other humble attacks
it is becoming increasingly difficult in
today's hyper-connected environment as
more corporate applications migrate to
both public and private clouds
additionally modern applications are
also frequently virtualized and
dispersed across several locations some
outside the physical control of the itt
network traffic and infrastructure must
be protected in these cases since
assaults on businesses are increasing
every single day
we now understood the basics of network
security
but we need to understand how network
security works in the next section in
slightly more detail
network security revolves around two
processes authentication and
authorization
the first process which is
authentication is similar to access
paths which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building
in other words authentication checks and
verifies that it is indeed the user
belonging to the network who is trying
to access or enter it thereby preventing
unauthorized intrusions
next comes authorization
this process decides the level of access
provided to the recently authenticated
user
for example
network admin needs access to the entire
network whereas those working within it
probably need access to only certain
areas within the network
based on the network user's role the
process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization
today's network architecture is complex
and faces a threat environment that is
always changing and attackers that are
always trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities
these vulnerabilities can exist in many
areas including devices data
applications users and locations
for this reason many network security
management tools and applications are in
use today that address individual
threats
when just a few minutes of down times
can cause widespread disruption and
massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place beforehand
now that we know a little about network
security and it's working let's cover
the different types of network security
the fundamental tenet of network
security is the layering protection for
massive networks and stored data that
ensure the acceptance of rules and
regulations
as a whole there are three types
the first of which is physical security
the next being technical and the third
being administrative
let's look into physical security first
this is the most basic level that
includes protecting data and network
through unauthorized personnel from
acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network
these include external peripherals and
routers that might be used for cable
connections
the same can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems
physical security is critical especially
for small businesses that do not have
many resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large firms
when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions
this kind fulfills two functions
one is defense against unauthorized
users
the other is a defense against
malevolent actions
the last category is administrative
this level of network security protects
user behavior like how the permission
has been granted and how the
authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks
this level also suggests necessary
amendments that have to be done to the
infrastructure
i think that's all the basics that we
need to cover on network security in
which our next topic we're going to go
through two mediums of network security
which are the transport layer and the
application layer
so transport layer is a way to secure
information as it is carried over the
internet with users browsing websites
emails instant messaging etc
tls aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties through the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all communications
the connection employs lighter symmetric
cryptography to save bandwidth and
processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface
poor app layer security can lead to
performance and stability issues data
theft and in some cases the network
being taken down
examples of application layer attacks
include distributed denial of service
attacks or ddos attacks
http flags sql injections
cross-site scripting etc
most organizations have an arsenal of
application layer security protections
to combat these and more such as web
application firewalls secure web gateway
services etc
now that we have the theory behind
network security has been covered in
detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security policies
the first two to be covered in this
section is a firework
a firewall is a type of network security
device that keeps track of incoming and
outgoing network traffic and it decides
which traffic to allow or deny in
accordance to a set of security rules
for more than 25 years fireballs have
served as network security's first line
of defense they provide a barrier
between trustworthy internal protected
and regulated networks from shady
external networks like the internet at
some point
the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private network or vpn for
it's an encrypted connection between a
device and a network via the internet
the encryptment connection is the secure
transmission of sensitive data
it makes it impossible for unauthorized
parties to eavesdrop on the traffic and
enables remote work for the user
the usage of vpn technology is common in
both corporate and personal networks
next we cover the importance of
inclusion prevention systems in network
security or ips frameworks
an intrusion prevention system is a
network security tool that continually
scans the network for harmful activity
and responds to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it
it can be either hardware or software
it's more sophisticated than an
inclusion detection system or an ids
framework which can just warn an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an ips it actually takes against that
activity
the next tool in this section and the
final one are going to be behavioral
analytics
behavior analytics focus more on the
statistics that are being carried over
and stored through months and years of
usage when some kind of similar pattern
is noted but the idea administrator can
detect some kind of attack the similar
attacks can be stopped and the security
can be further enhanced
another day i have covered all that we
need to know about network security the
necessary tools such different types etc
let's go to the benefits of network
security as a whole
the first which is protection against
external threats
the objective for cyber assaults can be
as varied as the defenders themselves
although they are typically initiated
for financial gain whether they are
industrial spies hacktivists or cyber
criminals these bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert the attacks are
getting
a strong cyber security posture that
considers routine software updates may
assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry points
the next benefit is protection against
internal threats
the human aspect continues to be the
cyber security system's weakest link
insider risk can originate from current
or former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright evil
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threads to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive disasters
the third benefit is increased
productivity
it is nearly impossible for employees to
function when network and personal
devices are slowed to a crawl by viruses
and other cyber attacks during the
operation of website and for the company
to run
you must significantly minimize
violations and the amount of downtime
required to fix the breach by
implementing various cybersecurity
measures such as enhanced firewalls
wireless scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email phishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by education and
training another benefit is
brand trust and reputation
customer retention is one of the most
crucial elements in business development
customers today place a premium on
maintaining brand loyalty through a
strong cyber security stance since this
is the fastest way to get other
businesses back get referrals and sell
more tickets overall
additionally it helps manufacturers get
on the vendor list with bigger companies
as a part of the supply chain which is
only as strong as its weakest link this
opens possibilities of potential future
endeavors and development
it's all really the all for the
theoretical part of network security
after covering so many topics let's go
through a small demonstration to drive
home this topic's importance so one of
the first things we're going to cover is
the installation of nmap
what are we using right now is actually
vmware a re-running an instance of a
linux distribution known as parrot
security operating system
the parrot security os is a debian based
linux distribution that is catered more
towards ethical hackers and penetration
testers
the harvard is created more is it comes
pre-installed with a lot of tools that
ethical hackers need including nmap so
let's say you're using another debian
based level distribution
if you want to install nmap you can go
with the command of sudo
apt which is the package manager
install
nmap
and just press enter at this point it's
going to ask you for your administrative
password because of the sudo command
which you have used now this epd will
change depending on the distribution
let's say using a distribution that is
based on arch linux that will be
different if there is some other
distribution which is built from scratch
the commands will differ but more or
less a lot of the distributions the main
stream distributions that people use
like ubuntu zorin os max mint they are
debian bs so you're just going to be
using sudo apt install nmap
if you give your administrator password
here
it's going to see that nmap is
smashed manually installed and it is
already the newest version at this point
if you do not have an app in your
distribution it's going to install the
necessary package files
if i just use the nmap command you can
see some help lines where it basically
says what kind of flags you can use what
are some of the most common commands the
version etc it gives a small sample for
the usage of nmap
now
the first one of the most basic
functions of nmap is to identify active
hosts on your network
and app does this by using a ping scan
or sometimes it's called a pink suite
this identifies all of the ip addresses
that are currently online without
sending any packets to these hosts
to run the command we're just going to
go with let me just clear the screen for
now
another thing you have to do before
running nmap just for our ease of use is
we're going to use the sudo su command
this will turn our console into an
administrator console so let's say we
want to use some drivers or some
external adapters or anything that
requires an initiative permission we
don't have to use the admin password
again and again
just going to give it a bit of time for
it to recognize
okay now that you see uh this dollar
sign has changed into a hash symbol
which means we now have root access
of this console right now of this
terminal so what we're going to do for
the ping suite where we have to check
existing course is you're going to use
the command in map
minus sp
and go with the id address
of the current subnet that you're in
which is always going to be minus one to
it uh it's always going to be 192 and
168.1.1
the 24 bracket
so this is going to take some time
considering this is going to check all
the hosts
in this particular subnet
the command then returns a list of posts
on your network which is this and the
total number of assigned ip addresses if
you can spot like any ip addresses that
you cannot account for in your network
or your server you can then further
commands to investigate them further
using nmap itself
now coming to another feature of nmap
which is a very important usage is
when scanning posts and mac commands can
use server names ip addresses or even
ip6 addresses
a basic and map command will produce
information about the given host
so to run a basic port scan we can just
use the nmap command with the ip address
of the device or the ip address that we
are targeting
so for now the host machine that i am
using currently has this current ip
address
if you can see the current ip address is
192.168.1.22
as it's written in the ipv4 address
preferred section
so now we're going to try and attack
this host machine using nmap on parent
security operating system
so we're just going to go with the end
map
192 162
and press enter and it's going to start
scanning the host for different services
and iap address
that are being run on the system
the speed of these scans usually depends
on how quick the processor is and also
how quickly the two machines can connect
with each other but two machines i mean
the virtual machine in this case and the
machine that is being attacked which is
right now the host machine which is
running vmware workstation
as you can see the post scanning is
complete for this particular ip address
and you can see the number of ports is
mentioned and the services that these
posts are used for is also mentioned it
says which of these are open for example
53 tcp port we can see it is closed
while some of the other ports are open
now one more feature of nmap is the
ability to guess the operating system of
the ip address that we are attacking
for that we need to add one more flag
which is going to go with the normal
command is nmap minus 4
and
the regular appearance that we are in
the process of attacking
let's give it a few minutes to run the
scan and it will try and put a small
guess on the operating system that this
host might be running
this guest might not always be accurate
but it puts a small idea and this is
much more accurate in the case of
actually unix-based operating system
other than windows based operating
systems may be able to detect that if it
is a windows or linux macintosh
and so on
but it may have difficulty finding exact
single versions which becomes easier in
the case of linux because we can
identify different distributions by some
of the kernels
which and most of the vulnerabilities
comes from the kernels and not the
particular distributions
as you can see the os detection guess is
complete and you can see aggressive os
guesses over here which is microsoft
windows xp service pack or windows
server and there's the 19 yes that is
mostly
like i mentioned if you can guess if it
is a windows based system you can apply
the vulnerabilities and the exploits
accordingly
now at times you may need to detect
service version and the
and similar information from these open
ports actually this is useful for
troubleshooting and scanning for
vulnerabilities or locating services
that need to be updated considering a
lot of the new updates are used to fix
these kind of open vulnerabilities so
the flag that we're going to use in this
case is minus
s3 or hyphen s3
this is going to change but the nmap and
the ip address of the whole system
staying consistent
a lot of the services that are being run
on these ports are often not the most
safe for example apache web server which
is a very common web server being used
for even local and global projects
a lot of the older versions used to have
systems that can allow privilege
escalations or other vulnerabilities
that can allow hacker to get into your
system without even you getting a trace
of it
so the updated versions tend to fix
these as quickly as possible and most of
these versions do not circulate in the
real world but can be used for ethical
hacking and testing on how these
validate and how these vulnerabilities
can be attacked further
now with the sv command scan is complete
you can see that it is mentioning some
of the version of the services that are
being run on the particular post
once again like i mentioned using these
version numbers you can identify
particular vulnerabilities and use the
exploits designed for these
vulnerabilities to gain access to the
system
another thing that nmap does well is
port scanning it's all the basic
utilities actually that nmap offers and
consequently there are few ways that
this command can be customized further
for example to come to start a port scan
we're going to use the flag of my ipin p
we're going to specify a random port for
example 443 which we know it will be
open because it is the port used for
https connections which is obviously
essential for you to access the internet
and once again we are going to use the
ip address for local host
as the test machine that are being
attacked
as you can see it clearly states that
the 44th report is open as expected
now you can use multiple ports you can
check multiple ports this way for
example and map iphone
address again
and it's going to show
the state of all the three ports now you
can see this filter part here which
which does not mean it is open and it
cannot be exploited in any way at least
right now maybe there is any other
service that is being run it can be
exploited further but right now it is in
a filtered condition
that is how we can actually scan for
multiple ports together you can also uh
we can also use actually
in a sports carrying in a range format
for example
let's say we're going to scan the ports
from 200
to 300 and once again going to use the
hyphen key flag
then
the ip address of the system being
attacked
it's going to scan all the posts from
200 to 300 and mention what are the
posts that are open filtered or just
straight up closed
as you can see
all the 101 scan ports are in ignore
state for example if we try to scan a
range in
a more reasonable range for example uh
four four three two
four percents
that's it
we'll keep the ip address similar
and you can see two of them are open and
two of them are filtered for different
different reasons this is how you can
find out which of the posts are liable
for exploitation before attacking these
kind of devices
with this we have reached the end of
this interactive full course session
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you